million theaters this weekend Teen
Titans go to the movies and Mission
Impossible fall out this is your weekend
ticket Tom Cruise is at it again with
the return of Ethan Hunt and Mission
Impossible fall out this is the sixth
film in the Mission Impossible movie
franchise that all started 22 years ago
in 1996 in this installment
Ethan Hunt must choose to accept a
mission that seems impossible all the
while being chased by bad guys and
proving to the good guys that he too is
a good guy wait are we sure that's the
synopsis of this Mission Impossible
movie who doesn't want to see Tom Cruise
still looking as good as he did in risky
business while doing his own stunts and
actually flying a freaking helicopter
I'm not only flying it
I'm also acting and I'm setting frames
also I mean at times I had to rotor
blades you know write off like this
close to the edge eclipse this movie
through you if you're into the mission
impossible franchise you enjoy movies
from one of the last true classic movie
stars Tom Cruise or you just want to see
if maybe this time Ethan Hunt doesn't
complete his mission I think he does
the movie that actually does look pretty
good Teen Titans go to the movies and so
should you
Teen Titans go to the movies is both the
name of the movie and the plot summary
in this meta action comedy animated
superhero movie based on the TV show
Teen Titans go
our heroes realized that basically every
other superhero ever has had a movie
made about them and they want their
slice of the silver screen after
Hollywood rejects them they decide their
best option is to find a nemesis and
they do Deadpool Deadpool what why does
everybody think of Deadpool
I thought Deadpool was a good guy by the
way he should be saying that he's not me
okay cuz I came out like way before he
did this movie is for you this weekend
if you're looking for a fun family
action comedy you or your kids are a fan
of the TV show Teen Titans go or if you
find Will Arnett's voice as soothing as
I that is your weekend ticket if you
choose to accept it what's your favorite
Tom Cruise movie check back next week PO
[Music]